– Auf gar keinen Fall!
– Aber wieso? Dadurch ist das Risiko
für euch nicht so hoch.
– Pepe, ich weiß nicht,
ob du uns richtig verstanden hast,
aber es gibt kein Risiko mehr,
weil es nämlich keinen Deal mehr gibt.
– Ich weiß auch nicht,
ob das ’ne gute Idee ist.
Der will für sein Geld 50 Prozent
von unserem Geschäft haben!
Das ist viel zu viel!
– Das war doch klar, dass der
uns nicht einfach so viel Geld gibt.
– Nein, das war nicht klar.
Und ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass er
euer Geschäftspartner werden will
und 50 Prozent fordert.
– Die bekommt er ganz sicher nicht,
denn wir brauchen ihn nicht.
– Ich arbeite jedenfalls nicht umsonst.
– Das sollst du auch nicht.
Mir war die ganze Sache
sowieso viel zu riskant!
– Tarek …
– Was denn?
Mich wundert, dass du unser
Restaurant größer machen willst.
Bist du unzufrieden?
– Nein.
– Max? Was ist der Plan?
– Es tut mir leid, Pepe.
Tarek hat recht.
Es ist unser Restaurant.
Wir wollen keinen Investor.